so today we're working on my weaknesses
finding out where my sticking points are
with estate agents
and sort of working through them finding
out exactly
what i need to do to get over that to
get my deals coming a bit quicker the
real issue is i'm valuing it at 110 and
i'm paying 75 so i'm at 20 and i don't
really want to go that low
if it values at 120 i'll buy it today
but i'm conservative on that
but if you're borrowing money to do it
in the first place and you can leave
that money in
what's the ish
i don't really know i think you need to
do it just for the confidence
because at the moment you've got all
this knowledge but at the moment it's
theoretical
yeah you're gonna be able to actually
exercise it and even if the video
doesn't work out
to be the best deal in the world and
it's like it's actually
an average to decent deal it's not quite
the standard
i mean geez we gotta start somewhere oh
i don't take eight
i'm gonna do what i did to the other
ishmael now and i'm gonna make you just
buy it now
you need to look at the survey you've
already got that you need to get the
legal pack
i'm tired of talking go sort that out
now go to the dining room call your
sister
buy that house sort it all out
go buy that house yeah i want you i'll
make you a cup of tea once you've done
it
if i drink tea what do you want you go
by the house
[Music]
we yeah have the capacity at the moment
um
but he would suggest you're going to
negotiate that's gonna ring
um one that samuel recommends
good afternoon i was ringing up to see
if i can get
um someone to look at a legal pack for
me the property i want to purchase
i'm buying it for 75 000 plus
legal um plus auction fees
and the other person solicitors
assuming they don't pick up anything i
didn't
then i'll ring paul fosh and make an
offer
of 75 then wait for him to come back
solicitor said they can't
do legal packs i run sam hawkings and
they said we can
we'll get back to you today after we've
checked it okay so they're gonna check
it today and do it so here's what you
need then
you need confidence
you need to get in with estate agents
and you need to take massive action
yeah that's it and
you can you do your personal stuff which
is great but you need to continually
deliberately focus on solutions not
problems positives not negatives
yeah i have been doing that you know
didn't really go that way actually they
said no and they said there's
so near the end i spoke to sam hawkins
gonna get done tomorrow see i would have
said
it went really well i actually uh i
spoke to sam hawking he's going to get
it done by
the end of the day by tomorrow but in my
mind it's just like that's a positive
outcome
but you automatically focused on what
didn't go well rather than what did
that's a good point you see i'm saying
yeah no because i focused on the first
listener i run rather than the
overall i always forget the negative bit
rinsing repeat
that's the plan rinse and repeat that
isn't even the plan that's the process
and it's gonna happen
in terms of agents i think it's going to
massively help you now
being able to say all right i've got one
going through actually at the minute
in um sw whatever i'm looking for
similar type of stuff
show them that is what you're looking
for yeah you need to go into these
stages
and you just ship when it's going to
wales
i just as soon as i find a property
which is potential i'll go
i wouldn't even do that i'd go without a
property
show them that property and say i'm
looking for stuff like this and you got
anything
another coffee with them what are you
doing on now
we'll be here we can even jump on the
call potentially
that would help i don't think we need to
and book a coffee with them and say
i'm an investor i'm looking for
properties that i can add value
to and then refinance i know it's really
busy at the moment
i know that everyone's queuing up for
good deals
but i'm a serious investor i'd love to
come in and talk to you about what i'm
looking for
over a cafe and and you know i just
wondered if i'd be able to pop in some
time
next week for 20 minutes
and instead of going to a few houses
you're going to build relationships
because you know that good deals come
from good relationships not from right
yeah move better off spending a day in
south wales
having six coffees with agents then
going and viewing six houses
makes sense yeah that should be your
goal so
give someone a call right now i'm all
listening and we'll give you some tips
tell them
i know that when the property comes on
online you've probably got 20 other
people for it so what from the bottom of
them what do i need to do
to get you to pick up the phone to me
because i'm i've got this little
property going
going through right now in auction terms
in s
whatever it is yeah so can we sit down
for a coffee
all right give him a call let's see what
happens be really friendly and smile
when you're on the phone
energy energy big energy means big mama
yeah stan good idea
please leave a message
[Applause]
[Music]
oh well i'll run another one remember
the outcome of the phone call
is to have an appointment with with
someone
do you want me to phone one person so
you can see what what i would say
you can model it around that yeah it's
probably a good idea right
and by the way again with this property
that you're buying at the minute
i can just imagine ishmael you're the
kind of person that would be thinking oh
it's not done yet
like so when you speak to the agents you
might say well i'm actually
thinking of putting forward on offering
one in sa i'm like
i've got them currently in essay 14. i'm
like claiming it i'm owning it before i
own it
that's called faith yeah and you know
what faith you need faith in business
because faith
is basically seeing something that's not
quite there yet
seeing the unseen yeah every property
developer has faith because you've got
to be able to see the vision of what the
project's going to look like before you
lift a brick
you speak it out you speaking to
existence all right give them a call
can i say as well ishmael see what sam
was doing as well see a minute ago
he was sitting down no now he's doing
calls to see how he's pacing the floor
he's ready yeah
i'm like a lion but you see that's the
difference you see i'm saying it's that
energy
hello i hope you're well my name is
samuel i'm basically
i'm a property investor and i'm looking
for a little investment in your sort of
neck of the woods i've got one at the
moment i'm just looking for a second
a second property um okay
um so i'm looking generally speaking
this is between 50 and 100
000 i am looking for stuff that i can
add value to
so i mean the property that i've just
bought at the moment was an auction
property but
it needs maybe about 10 15 000 pounds
spending on it
um
does that need any work doing on it or
is that in yeah
okay that sounds interesting
um i understand i i
really i really appreciate your um
you know just being upfront about it he
needs 85 as an absolute minimum
i don't know
yeah all right that's fair enough and
what's it on for sorry what did you say
the asking price is
89.99 nine 89.95 and what's the post
what was she sorry i didn't catch your
name by the way my name is tammy
uh i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
struggle with that
my parents are from wales say that again
this property if it was done up really
nice to a higher standard
what do you think the value might be 114
okay
fair enough well it looks it looks
potent it looks like a potential i mean
generally speaking
like properties uh and i've been i've
been investing for
for quite a while so i kind of i've got
quite a sort of
a strict idea of exactly what i want in
mind if if it fits then great
what what normally i look for is
problems that i can buy i mean 85
90 000 is perfectly within budget i've
got
cash in the bank um you know so that
that's not a problem mortgage and stuff
would wouldn't even wouldn't even need a
mortgage because i
tend to buy cash but then what i do is
i'll do them up
and then i refinance them once they're
done
oh wow well i thought i was an expert
but um
20 years he definitely beats me i've
been in the game for about 12 years and
that started in 2008
um fantastic i mean it looks interesting
when would you if i was to book a
viewing on it when would you be able to
show me
around
all right let me just have a little look
in my diary one second let me just have
a point
i don't care about the house i care
about her yeah yeah
she's been again for 20 years she knows
what she's doing i'm gonna do that just
to get in with her
yeah yeah but uh potentially friday if
that works it'll actually be my
business partner that will be um that
will be coming
his name is ishmael i'm i'm literally
with him right now
um but it it friday works we friday
afternoon
yeah that's fine all right hey hi me
again i just want to say thank you so
much um for that and also as well um
if anything else comes up um if there's
any other
if anything pops up i know that at the
minute you've got this one but
i mean you know ishmael's going to be in
the area we are um
always looking for as many as many deals
as we can find
the money that you're about to spend on
that house
screenshot that and show that to her
qualify yourself hey here's my money
here's my id
here's what i'm looking for case study
relationships your focus needs to be not
houses
relationships here's the great thing as
well sometimes in trying to find a
relationship over a deal
you'll accidentally find the deal yeah
so i just was like
let me further the state agent i'm not
ringing about a particular house
i'm not on right now i'm just ringing an
estate agent to say hey i'm looking for
investments
this is what i'm looking for oh i've
actually got one
i ran for the relationship i got the
deal one set that could be a good deal
if you do what we just did there though
instead of
looking for houses on right move yeah do
you think things will change
i think so yeah so i'm going to be
speaking to estate agents
i'm going to book viewings to just make
relationships with estate agents
um so book appointments with estate
agents rather than just booking the
viewing and then just going around
having a quick chat with them i'm
actually gonna sit down with them tell
them what i'm looking for
tell them who i am tell them what that
i've got the money ready to invest
that's what i'll be doing moving forward
so i think that's
uh being a really good day and i'm going
to go smash it at the park
in the next couple of weeks